bienvenue à vous qui nous rejoignait sur
sensation je reçois Bruno millienne
président du Mouvement Démocrate des
Yvelines
l'hebdo-politique Nicolas kirinovitz
Bruno millième bonsoir vous êtes né au
Laos le 28 novembre 1959 vous avez donc
55 ans vous êtes marié et père de trois
enfants le Laos la Côte d'Ivoire le
Maroc jusqu'à vos 18 ans vous avez eu la
chance de beaucoup voyager avec vos
parents quels enseignements vous en avez
tiré de ces multiples voyages alors
d'abord je vais vous mettre une toute
petite précision je suis pas né au
là-haut je suis né à Argenteuil
malheureusement ça fait moins exotique
mais je suis parti tout de suite
d'accord tout de suite au Laos elle
était enseignante donc j'avais des
grands toute ma petite enfance sur la
hausse l'enseignement qu'on en tire il
est il est d'abord je pense une
ouverture d'esprit incroyable et puis un
voyage
j'allais dire initiatique oui on peut
dire ça comme ça assez fantastique à la
rencontre de culture différente
qui vous font aimer et respecter les
autres et je pense que là j'ai un peu
des mentions parce que je pense aux
attentats de ce week-end et à ceux du 11
janvier à Paris et je pense que ça c'est
pour les gens comme moi qui ont été
élevés à l'étranger dans avec
différentes cultures c'est quelque chose
non seulement d'incompréhensible mais
d'un concevable vous avez fait une halte
à la Faculté de médecine de Xavier
Bichat à Paris mais les études ce n'est
pas forcément pour vous c'est vous qui
le dites vous vous tournez vers le
journaliste sportif avant de basculer du
côté technique et de rejoindre le groupe
M6 où vous êtes devenu directeur de la
continuité de l'antenne votre engagement
politique a été plutôt tardif puisqu'il
date de la création du MoDem en 2007 à
partir de cette année-là vous participez
à la campagne présidentielle vous
soutenez des candidats au législatives
et aux municipales l'an passé vous avez
été élu conseiller municipal à
Jumeauville vous étiez candidat aux
européennes sur la liste udi modem et
vous êtes devenu président du Mouvement
Démocrate des Yvelines en novembre
dernier avec vous nous évoquons
l'actualité du MoDem et nous reviendrons
sur la campagne pour les départementales
dans les Yvelines mais tout de suite
c'est l'heure du money time
le money time
on commence donc Bruno millenienne avec
le money time c'est une série de
questions-réponses rapides le but ça va
prendre à mieux vous connaître et avoir
et voir si vous suivez bien l'actualité
si vous la connaissez bien et votre avis
là-dessus aujourd'hui d'après les
barométriephe un tiers des demandeurs
d'emploi affirme avoir été victime de
discriminations à l'embauche est-ce que
être étranger aujourd'hui en France
avoir plus de 55 ans être enceinte ou
avoir un style vestimentaire trop décalé
c'est un frein dans notre vie
professionnelle malheureusement je pense
que oui malheureusement je pense que oui
il y a des discriminations qui sont pas
seulement du haut faciès ou au nom il y
a des discriminations aussi avec les
femmes et ça c'est dommage et je pense
que depuis une trentaine d'années on a
laissé un petit peu dériver ça ça
n'existait pas avant alors évidemment
j'ai vécu à l'étranger j'ai pas connu
l'école en France mais j'ai connu sur ma
dernière année quand j'ai passé le bac
j'avais pas de juifs ou de musulmans
comme copain j'avais des Français de
confession musulmane de confession juive
et il y avait pas de différence et au
fur et à mesure du temps tout cela c'est
d'éliter et même sur quand on reçoit
c'est pas mon cas mais on le voit assez
souvent quand on soit un CV si vous
reportez pas le bon nom il le CV
peut-être pas lu la France vient de
vendre pour la première fois son avion
de chasse le Rafale l'acheteur c'est
l'Égypte mais savez-vous combien
d'avions précisément ont été vendus et
le montant du contrat c'est assez
faramineux quand même alors le montant
du contrat c'est en milliards
et c'est 24 avions exactement l'avenir
de la réserve parlementaire en question
chaque député dispose d'au moins 130 000
euros qu'il peut distribuer librement à
des communes ou à des associations cette
cagnotte faut-il la supprimer ou imposer
encore plus de transparence dans les
attributions peut-être à faire plus de
transparence dans les attributions parce
que malheureusement cette cagnotte des
députés je le sais puisque je vis dans
une petite commune on en a besoin un
défaut et une qualité pour caractériser
François Bayrou le président du MoDem
mon Dieu une qualité
la vérité la droiture
à défaut
la solitude peut-être comment vous
informez-vous presse écrite web télé ou
radio personnellement les trois vous
faites les trois oui je suis très
souvent sur le Web mais le matin radio
et puis la télé forcément je vis dedans
donc savez-vous la plateforme de partage
de vidéo qui fait ces 10 ans
actuellement YouTube exactement c'est
YouTube et c'est le clip Gangnam style
du coréen psy qui détient le record du
nombre de vues avec plus de 2 milliards
le MP va lancer un groupe de travail sur
la place de l'islam en France le
gouvernement lui va lancer une série de
consultations sur l'influence des Frères
musulmans et des mouvements salafistes
est-ce aujourd'hui une priorité est-ce
qu'on a on a raison de s'intéresser à ça
vous pensez la raison de s'intéresser à
ça mais je pense qu'il y a deux facteurs
qu'on a laissé tomber de but très
longtemps et qui ont amené à se
communautarisme c'est l'éducation et
l'emploi artiste auréolé d'une Victoire
de la Musique Christine and the Queen's
Julien Doré Calogero Alain Souchon quel
est parmi ces noms là votre artiste
préféré à vous Julien Doré Julien Doré
la ministre de l'Éducation nationale
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem a écarté l'idée
de supprimer les notes à l'école
primaire bonne ou mauvaise décision
vous avez peut-être un avis là-dessus
oui j'ai un avis c'est un vieux serpent
de merde les notes qui qu'on doit
supprimer ou pas je pense que il y a pas
d'avis il y a simplement avoir une
pédagogie meilleure et intéresser les
enfants à l'école voilà après les notes
elles peuvent être traumatisantes mais
faut savoir les expliquer vous l'homme
de télé quel regard portez-vous dessus
aujourd'hui sur la télé abusé amusé ou
satisfait de son évolution
je suis un peu abusé je pense qu'on a
perdu en liberté je me rappelle d'une
époque dans les années 80 où la
télévision était beaucoup plus libre
avec des émissions comme celle de Michel
Polac qui était elle polémiste mais il y
avait deux grandes émissions je pense à
Jacques Chancel notamment et le Grand
Échiquier ça c'était des émissions
culturelles que tout le monde regardait
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on tire un petit
peu le chaud vers le bas
les dossiers
premier thème de cette hebdopolitique en
compagnie de Bruno Milian président du
MoDem 78 on va parler de votre partie de
son actualité d'un point de vue national
et dans une seconde partie on fera la
même chose mais d'un point de vue
départemental Bruno millienne dites-nous
quel regard aujourd'hui vous vous portez
sur le modem est-ce que vous jugez son
action aujourd'hui et satisfaisante et
efficace ou insuffisante au contraire
alors je pense que pour parler du MoDem
au niveau national on a tenté une
aventure à partir de 2007 qui était
claire c'était d'imposer une autre façon
de faire de la politique alors nous a
mis au centre moi je veux bien parce
qu'il faut classifier les gens il faut
bien les mettre quelque part vous seriez
où pour vous et ben on serait pas on est
j'irai qu'on est devant mais je dirais
surtout qu'on est pragmatique et
réaliste bon admettons on est au centre
d'accord on a on a eu suite à au 18% un
peu plus même de François Bayrou à la
présidentielle en 2007 comme une espèce
de vague et d'espoir et on pensait
s'installer durer durablement à tous les
échelons l'échiquier politique force et
de constater que
parce que je pense que le parti est
jeune n'oubliez pas quand même que on a
que 7 ans d'existence à ses premières
choses on a peut-être pas le
savoir-faire de formation qui ont des
traditions beaucoup plus anciennes comme
l'UMP qui est une émanation du RPM ou le
PS ou même l'UDI si on prend le cas de
l'UDI il se met ce n'est qu'une
émanation de l'UMP ils étaient à l'UMP
avant ils ont profité de de toute cette
expérience acquise à l'UMP pour après
pouvoir sortir et être en ordre de
bataille avec un groupe parlementaire
ils ont de l'argent je vais vous donner
un exemple simple je crois que le le
budget je vais pas donner le chiffre
mais le budget comparatif entre l'UMP et
le modem est de 1 à 100 voilà
pour l'instant vous pensez vous êtes au
creux de la vague et que plus tard
finalement ça va repartir c'est un
mauvais moment à patient moi ce que je
pense sincèrement c'est que
c'est pour ça un petit peu que je l'ai
suivi en dehors de son côté droit parce
que je pense que s'il y avait eu des
affaires sur François bayroule depuis
longtemps vu que c'est un peu le poil à
gratter de ça a été pour certains
dont ma mère qui était enseignante un
très bon ministre
pourtant socialiste ma mère donc il
n'avait rien à voir avec le centre
et je pense que j'ai suivi pour ça pour
sa droiture et cette espèce de loyauté
et se fait que effectivement il fasse
passer l'humain avant toute chose c'est
à dire que tous les projets qu'il a
monté l'humain était au centre de tout
avec des relations relativement simples
alors ça va remonter je suis pas
vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui il y a
quand même une un petit quelque chose
qui bouge au niveau politique en France
c'est que le PS ne va pas si bien que ça
on le sait très bien il est un peu
séparé en deux ailes qui vont avoir du
mal à se réconcilier une aile un petit
peu plus dure et dogmatique et une aire
une aile plus sociale libérale lui c'est
en quelque sorte la même chose MP c'est
la même chose avec une droite un petit
peu plus dure et puis une droite plus
modérée incarner notamment entre autres
par Alain Juppé et et face à ces deux
mastodontes on une force qui émerge qui
elle n'est pas ma tasse de thé et vous
vous en doutez c'est le Front national
donc je ne vois pas comment en
continuant à rester dans ce système
qu'on a en ce moment en France avec deux
gros mastodontes qui ne sont pas unis
d'accord à l'intérieur même de leur base
face à un FN qui monte on va pouvoir
s'en sortir et arrêter et endiguer ce
flot de vote FN qui grandit à l'élection
après élections
du PS et du MP qui serait prêt à vous
rejoindre côté franchement ça se
dessinait déjà un petit peu avant les
événements du 11 janvier
depuis ce qui s'est passé avec l'affaire
de Charlie Hebdo ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à Copenhague je pense qu'il
y a un moment où il faut qu'on arrête je
crois que j'avais écrit je sais plus
quelque part que nos Bizzbee politique
semblait bien mesquines par rapport à
tout ce qui se passe dans le monde donc
j'aimerais bien que on arrête un instant
ça que les gens de bonne volonté se
parlent parce que l'important c'est de
se parler peu importe d'où on vient dès
l'instant où on n'est pas ni trop
dogmatique ni trop extremiste et qu'on
soit capable de mettre un petit mouchoir
sur ses convictions profondes pour
l'intérêt général je crois qu'on en a
vraiment besoin alors le parti à la mode
au centre ça semble être devenu l'UDI en
tout cas ces dernières élections sur les
derniers suffrages l'Union des
démocrates et indépendant quel est le
rapport quel doit être le rapport entre
le modem et Ludi est-ce que c'est vu
comme un allié un défectible est-ce que
c'est vu comme un concurrent quelque
part comment on doit comment le modem
doit-il gérer sa nous avec l'autre
partie du centre nous on gère pas enfin
l'idée est un parti l'UDI est libre de
ses choix et fait ce qu'il veut il y
avait une initiative pour les Européens
l'alternative a très bien fonctionner
moi j'ai pas continué elle a très bien
fonctionné parce que d'abord l'UDI et le
modem au moins sur l'Europe on est on
est raccord totalement à 100%, il y a
pas de on est les seuls eurofiles
Français donc à partir de là ça ne
pouvait que fonctionner et c'est pas
forcément le cas d'un point de vue
national bah c'est plus compliqué parce
que que c'est plus compliqué parce que
d'abord l'UDI et quelque part je vous
l'ai dit une émanation de l'UMP lui dit
il y a quand même doit quand même
quelque chose à l'UMP on va être on va
être clair si s'ils ont des élus
aujourd'hui c'est quand même grâce à
l'UMP donc ça ça fausse un petit peu les
rapports même si j'entends ce que dit
Jean-Christophe Lagarde et pas et
j'apprécie hein le fait qu'il veuille
marteler avec force indépendance de lui
et tout je pense que le détachement
total du du parti pair ou mère appelait
ça comme vous voulez va prendre un petit
peu plus de temps voilà est-ce que sur
le long terme vous souhaitez que l'UDI
et le MoDem se rapproche fortement pour
pour avoir un centre on va dire plus
fort et qui puisse plus peser dans la
vie politique française et notamment vu
des élections présidentielles je sais
pas comment on peut voir cette alliance
réellement est-ce qu'il faut une fusion
des deux des deux centres pour un seul
grand centre est-ce qu'il faut une
plateforme commune en tout cas si vous
interrogez les militants de base ceux
qui sont sur le terrain ils le
souhaitent et vous homme politique local
j'aimerais
François Bayrou le président du MoDem
est également apprécié des Français
au-delà du parti c'est 37% d'opinion
favorables il arrive en troisième
position des personnalités politiques
est-il selon vous un bon chef un bon
leader de partie on lui reproche souvent
d'être un peu on va dire si je peux me
permettre un peu manque de charisme un
peu comme François Hollande est-ce que
vous trouvez ça justifiez ou pas oui
manque de charisme on peut le dire je
l'ai souvent entendu moi vous savez
après François Bayrou faut j'allais dire
faut savoir l'écouter il y a forcément
je suis au premier loge je l'écoute
souvent déjà je lui reconnais quelque
chose d'assez d'assez intéressant
tous les mots qu'il emploie ont une
place et un sens
toutes ces phrases sont construites
c'est un homme qui parle très bien
français qui est très cultivé et qui a
un discours qui est tout à fait
intelligible et audible et
après pourquoi la mayonnaise de prend
pas je saurais pas vous dire je suis le
plus mal placé pour vous le dire à la
limite je suis plus mal placé parce que
forcément si on épouse les tests du
modèle et si on épouse les tests de
François Bayrou on a un petit peu de mal
à voir pourquoi ça prend pas ailleurs
d'autant plus que quand j'en discute
avec des amis qui sont pas forcément de
mon bord politique ils sont tous à
reconnaître que ces idées sont
intéressantes et en tout cas lui
reconnaissent une chose c'est d'avoir eu
raison avant tout le monde François
Bayrou est loin devant Marine Le Pen en
termes d'opinion favorable à ce propos
le leader du MoDem a évoqué récemment la
montée en puissance du FN dans la vie
politique française il s'est prononcé en
faveur de la fin du scrutin majoritaire
et la mise en place de la
proportionnelle pour lui selon François
Bayrou c'est lorsque les extraits seront
dans les assemblées qu'on découvrira
leur incohérence et leur faiblesses
est-ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
aussi mais il pour sans raison Nicolas a
regardé ce qui se passe dans les mairies
que le Fnac conquis en mars 2014 il y a
quand même quelques petits couacs une
dans les Yvelines Mantes-la-Ville donc
bien sûr qu'il faut les laisser exercer
le pouvoir ces gens-là et puis de toute
façon on efface pas comme ça 25 % des
votants c'est pas possible ça c'est pas
démocratique donc je pense qu'il a
raison il faut il faut les laisser on va
dire un gros contingent Front national
ça changera quoi sincèrement honnêtement
ça changera quoi ça changera rien du
tout il faut les il faut les laisser
agir ces gens-là pour qu'enfin les gens
ouvrent les yeux et s'aperçoivent que le
FM en terme de solution c'est une
coquille vide parce que nous on le dit
mais bon personne nous croit la preuve
le modem a-t-il un rôle à jouer
finalement dans la montée enfin pour on
va dire lutter contre la montée du Front
national s'il faut lutter contre
bien sûr qu'on a un rôle à jouer on a un
rôle à jouer déjà de de parties
fédérateurs des réformistes je vous
parlais de cette plateforme
transpartizane tout à l'heure si on peut
nous jouer un rôle là-dessus et faire en
sorte que des gens qui sont finalement
pas si éloignés de ça les uns des autres
bien qu'ils se positionne les uns du
côté à gauche social libéral et l'autre
droite modérées il faut qu'on arrive à
les réunir et qu'on travaille ensemble
on évoqué tout à l'heure la question de
l'UDI abordons maintenant celle de l'UMP
on sait François Bayrou proche d'Alain
Juppé ce qui est loin d'être le cas avec
Nicolas Sarkozy le président du parti de
droite le MP d'un point de vue national
c'est un allié sur certains points et on
va dire un concurrent sur d'autres je
pense pas qu'il faut qu'il faille parler
en termes de concurrence vous voyez bien
que la donne un petit peu changé au
niveau de l'UMP il y a à l'UMP un
courant modéré
pragmatique et réaliste qui a envie de
travailler les projets sur le terrain
moi je pense que la politique regagnera
c'est l'aide de noblesse par les élus de
territoire donc tous les projets qu'on
pourra mener en commun avec le MP s'il
nous conviennent on le fera vous postez
souvent sur les réseaux sociaux des
messages visant à dire le président
l'UMP à titre personnel je parle au chef
du parti dans dans le département c'est
pas votre tasse de thé Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est les valeurs c'est simplement une
question de valeur c'est pas les miennes
et c'est celle d'Alain Juppé les vôtres
plus parce que Alain Juppé il y a quand
même d'abord je vais vous dire le gros
avantage de d'Alain Juppé qui est
présenté comme un défaut par certains
j'allais dire c'est son âge parce
qu'avec son âge et son expérience
d'abord il a acquis une stature d'homme
d'État et les Français peuvent être
assurés que si demain il remporte la
primaire et s'il gagne l'élection
présidentielle il aura 72 ans oui alors
il est en pleine forme Alain Juppé on
est bien d'accord donc si mais si il est
en pleine forme je vous le confirme le
jour où il mettra s'il peut mettre ses
fesses sur le fauteuil de présent de la
République ce sera pour bosser et pas
pour penser à sa réélection parce que je
pense qu'il ne fera qu'un mandat on
reproche souvent à votre partie à
François Bayrou d'avoir indiqué qu'il
voterait lui pour François Hollande à
l'élection au second tour en 2012 à
l'élection présidentielle c'était une
erreur à l'époque avec du recul
maintenant deux ans et demi plus tard
alors je vous fais une confidence très
claire vous regardez le résultat des
reports de voie en 2007 et ce en 2012
c'est exactement les mêmes un tiers un
tiers un tiers pour la droite un tiers
pour la gauche et un tiers qui ne se
sont pas prononcés donc le fait et en
plus Byro a parlé à titre personnel mais
comment voulez-vous qu'il fasse
autrement tout le monde connaissait son
illimité pour Nicolas Sarkozy le fait
que lui dise qu'il allait voter pour
François Hollande personnellement au nom
des valeurs pas au nom du programme
puisque même dans son allocution il a
dénoncé le programme en disant qu'il
serait intenable donc c'était logique il
pouvait pas faire autrement Alain Juppé
était sifflé récemment lors du conseil
national de l'UMP lorsqu'il a cité le
nom du MoDem dans le cadre d'une union
de la droite vous comprenez l'amertume
de certains électeurs ou en politique de
l'UMP deux ans et demi plus tard à
l'égard de votre partie deux ans et demi
plus tard je pense que la farce a assez
duré qui serait en Compass à autre chose
on arrive à la moitié de cette émission
on fait une pause musicale et on se
retrouve tout de suite on va parler du
MoDem mais dans les Yvelines cette fois
l'hebdo-politique Nicolas kerylovitz
deuxième partie de cette hebdopolitique
en compagnie de Bruno Millien président
du MoDem 78 on va parler de votre partie
dans le département déjà dites-nous pour
ceux qui ne le savent pas ils devaient
être nombreux combien vous êtes
d'adhérents au modem dans les Yvelines
on est
j'ai pas les chiffres définitifs et les
derniers chiffres mais on est entre 650
et 700 et c'est un chiffre qui est
stable qui baisse qui augmente on a
j'allais vous dire qu'à chaque élection
présidentielle on a des pertes mais on
organise derrière non
globalement ça varie peu on a des gens
qui reviennent là en revanche on a
beaucoup de nouveaux adhérents on a
beaucoup de primo-adhérents
de l'UMP absolument déçu du Parti
socialiste certains déçus de l'UDI je ne
sais pas pourquoi il faudra leur
demander et déçu d'une certaine dérive
droitière d'une partie de l'UMP dans
votre campagne pour la présidence du
MoDem 78 vous indiquez que votre partie
était en déficit d'image est-ce que ce
problème est résolu désormais maintenant
c'est vous à la présidence
c'est en marche d'être très jolie ou pas
oh ça va prendre du temps je pense qu'il
va falloir que ça prenne ça va prendre
un petit peu plus de temps l'image du
parti dans le 78 est également à égalité
avec l'image qu'on a au niveau national
donc voilà c'est sûr que tant qu'on a
pas
quelques dizaines d'élus en vue ça voilà
c'est plus difficile et puis j'ai pas
trop non plus que le tirer toujours
l'image du parti à moi et que je sois le
seul représentant du parti donc nous on
va mettre en place des choses dans les
Yvelines on va travailler parce que je
compare aujourd'hui le modem dans les
Yvelines à une femme dans une entreprise
un poste égal elle doit deux fois de
faire deux fois plus la preuve de ses
capacités donc on va bosser on va faire
des road show sur des thèmes qui
intéressent les Français et on va
circuler dans les Yvelines donc il y
aura un thème qu'on débattra pendant un
mois et demi ou deux mois dans les
Yvelines à chaque fois et après on
changera de thème et à chaque fois
les chefs de projets seront des
personnes différentes pour mettre
différentes personnes du parti en valeur
dans le dans le département et pour le
moment comment se passe votre mandat on
va dire votre début de mandat
écoutez ça se passe plutôt bien je crois
que d'abord les gens me connaissaient un
petit peu puisque j'ai assuré du
l'intérim de Bruno Tabary pendant près
de d'un an voilà on a un peu construit
toute cette aventure qu'on est en train
de commencer on l'a construite ensemble
alors le dossier chaud que vous avez eu
à gérer ces derniers temps c'était la
préparation des élections
départementales vous avez trouvé un
terrain d'entente avec la majorité
sortante ensemble pour les Yvelines qui
réunit l'UMP lui dit pour les
départementales c'est un accord qui vous
satisfait
en termes de place réservée je peux pas
vous dire qu'on est satisfait vous avez
deux suppléances
à Poissy l'idée qui a prévalu là-dessus
on s'est posé la question on s'est dit
on est en capacité d'aller sur les 20
cantons c'est pas un souci trouver deux
personnes pour aller faire les
cantonales un binôme en l'occurrence
on aurait pu très bien y aller y aller
pour faire allez on va être honnête
entre 8 et 12% et continuer une espèce
de spirale de l'échec dans le
département c'est pas franchement ma
tasse de thé donc on en a beaucoup
discuté en bureau départemental et on
s'est dit
compenser que le moment était venu
effectivement de renouer le dialogue qui
s'était un peu distendu notamment avec
les gens de l'UMP donc on est on est
allé voir Pierre Bellier je suis allé
voir Pierre Bédié on a discuté et comme
au niveau programmatique notamment sur
le Mantois Poissy enfin on va dire le
Val de Seine dans sa globalité on est on
partage à peu près les mêmes choses que
il y a une volonté effectivement de
construire des projets communs sur des
idées qui nous rassemblent on s'est dit
pourquoi pas y aller bien évidemment
quand on est arrivé vous doutez bien
qu'il y avait beaucoup de place qui
étaient prises en plus c'est difficile
on n'a pas de conseiller généraux
sortants d'accord on n'a pas de mère on
a peu de mer adjoint donc sur une
élection comme les élections
départementales ça laisse pas beaucoup
de place c'est mieux que rien quoi non
je dis pas c'est mieux que rien je dis
que c'est le début de quelque chose
voilà et cette alliance entre l'UMP et
le modem ça va durer dans le département
ou c'est uniquement pour ces élections
là je pense que ça va durer et vous le
verrez par la suite pour la bonne et
simple raison que
on a bien vu ce qu'a fait le Parti
socialiste depuis 2012 je pense que pas
grand monde ne s'attendait à cette
catastrophe
preuve qu'ils n'ont ils ont
insuffisamment préparé l'alternance
politique
et là on a plus le choix enfin on a plus
le choix c'est pas dans le sens négatif
que je le dis là maintenant il est temps
effectivement ce que je vous disais de
mettre toutes les bonnes volontés autour
de la table et de travailler ensemble
sur un projet commun pour le bien des
concitoyens c'est par exemple je vais le
citer parce que c'est sur cette mairie
là ça marche formidablement bien ça
marche bien aussi à Mantes-la-Jolie mais
sur Poissy avec car le livre c'est
quelque chose qu'on a mis en place il y
a trois conseillers municipaux modem
là-bas dont un maire adjoint et je peux
vous dire que le ça travaille ça
travaille dur et ça travaille dans
l'intérêt des pistes cahiers et c'est
exactement ça qu'on cherche donc
finalement là-dessus on peut pas avoir
tellement de différence puisque seul le
résultat perçu par les concitoyens
compte il y a quelques semaines vous
sembliez un peu critique vis-à-vis de
l'attitude de l'UDI pour pour ces
élections départementale quels sont vos
relations avec le parti de centre droit
et plus particulièrement avec Arnaud
Richard son président et des discussions
non il y en a pas trop j'ai pas couché
vous cacher que dans le département
c'est pas facile mais comme quand dans
des familles des cousins peuvent ne pas
être d'accord ça s'embrouille et puis
bah j'espère que un jour on sera
bibochera je crois que c'est l'intérêt
de tous quelle est l'adversaire numéro 1
de cette campagne du groupe Ensemble
pour les Yvelines c'est le Front
national le Parti socialiste ou les
autres partis de gauche
à personne je pense que le le
l'adversaire numéro 1 c'est le Front
national quel regard justement vous
portez sur le front national qui monte
qui monte dans le département ça vous
inquiète ou pas tant que ça finalement
vous dites que ensemble vous serez pas
du mal à les battre
ben c'est forcément inquiétant parce que
on sait pas où se situe la réalité du
vote est-ce que c'est un vote d'adhésion
je ne crois pas il y a un vote
contestataire c'est sûr quel est le
niveau entre les deux on sait pas trop
je suis inquiet parce que les thèses de
vous comprenez bien vu mon passé vu mon
enfant toutes ces tests de renfermement
sur soi de refermer les frontières de se
rabouir sur son soin personnel d'arrêter
l'euro qui est pour moi quelque chose de
totalement mortifère forcément ça
m'inquiète d'un côté ça m'inquiète et
d'un autre côté je me dis allez quand
bien même le Front national arriverait
au pouvoir en 2017 je pense qu'il n'aura
pas les moyens moi de gouverner parce
que l'assemblée ne sera pas à sa couleur
et c'est pour ça aussi qu'il faut que
vous soyez uni on va dire à droite et au
centre bah je pense qu'il faut qu'on
présente effectivement quelque chose qui
soit autre chose que l'UMP ou le PS
s'est affrontement qu'on connaît depuis
30 ans et qui ne fonctionne pas il faut
que vraiment tous les gens de bonne
volonté se mettent en marche et se
lèvent quand l'UMP à travers pierre
Bédié président sortant du Conseil
Général des Yvelines dit espérer le
Grand Chelem pour pour ces
départementales c'est-à-dire un conseil
général et un conseil départemental dans
le futur 100% du couleur de l'étiquette
ensemble pour les Yvelines vous vous le
souhaitez aussi ou alors pour le débat
pour la démocratie c'est pas forcément
souhaitable
oh oui et bien des gens qui me diront
que pour la démocratie c'est pas
souhaitable après si vous considérez que
le Conseil Général demain doit devenir
une espèce d'entreprise qui doit
fonctionner comme une entreprise vaut
mieux avoir une équipe soudée donc ça
serait pas forcément vous dites non mais
une équipe soudée ça veut dire des gens
qui ont porté le même projet aux
élections et qui se retrouvent ensemble
pour travailler enfin je moi je suis
issu de la société civile dans les
équipes que j'ai à gérer quand les
équipes ne sont pas soudées ça
fonctionne moins bien que quand elles
sont soudées voilà tout simplement un
mot maintenant sur l'abstention là c'est
très important pour ces élections
anciennement les cantonales je les dis
en 2011 elle dépasser les 55%, est-ce
que c'est pas finalement ça le premier
ennemi d'un parti qui se présente à ces
élections c'est plutôt l'abstention
c'est forcément l'abstention parce que
après quand vous prenez le pourcentage
des votants par rapport au pourcentage
des lecteurs vous voyez que ça manque un
petit peu de légitimité
l'abstention et c'est la vraie question
qu'on devrait se poser c'est pour ça que
cette cette plateforme transpartisane
j'y tiens beaucoup parce que aujourd'hui
il est clair que si on regarde les
résultats des abstentions sur les trois
dernières élections municipales
européennes et celles qui vont avoir
lieu là pour les départementales on
estime à peu près 58% si je ne m'abuse
ça veut dire quand même que plus d'un
Français sur deux ne se déplacera pas
pour voter pour les cantonales pour leur
département alors le département c'est
quand même le lien privilégié entre
entre l'État enfin entre le Conseil
général c'est bien privilégié entre le
département et les communes les communes
notamment les communes rurales sont le
département elles peuvent pas faire
grand-chose donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important c'est
quelqu'un qui affecte la vie des
concitoyens au quotidien c'est pas
quelque chose d'abstrait comme ça donc
il y a la pédagogie il y a proposé
encore une fois une autre offre
politique que celle traditionnelle qu'on
connaît depuis 30 ans
c'est la fin de cette hebdopolitique
merci Bruno milleniène d'avoir été notre
invité d'avoir répondu à nos questions